-I'm so happy you're here.
You just came back from a trip
I want to ask you about.
You went to Finland?
-I did. I did.
Went with friends, yeah.
-Yeah.
Why did you -- Why Finland?
Any connection?
-Um, so, okay -- So,
my boyfriend, Joe Tippett,
has an affinity for
photographing
the northern lights.
So this was, like,
the pilgrimage to see
the northern lights,
'cause he'd gone before.
So, we got a small group
of friends together,
we decided to go for New Year's,
and we had
the most unbelievable time.
-Yeah. It was just amazing.
-It was like a fairy tale.
It was --
Just couldn't believe my eyes.
-Almost can't believe
this photo's real,
but this is a photo --
-This isn't even really
a great photo.
Joe would be disappointed in
my -- This is my photography.
-But that looks like --
almost like a fake set on, like,
a Christmas --
-That actually --
This is awkward.
That is a fake photo from a set.
-Oh, yeah, I was gonna say,
'cause that doesn't look real.
Okay, good. But the real --
-If we could have them send --
-The real -- Yeah, send
the real photo eventually.
-Yeah.
-But, that -- So, you...
You see that, right?
And what do you do?
I mean, what --
How do you react?
And what is it?
What is it, the northern lights?
-Oh...science.
-I know. Yeah. I'm sorry to --
-No, it actually -- It's like --
It's particles of the atmosphere
interacting with space.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, is that real
or you just made that up?
-I think you can decide
for yourself.
-But you do that, and I go --
-I looked it up,
too, when I was there.
I mean, they have all
these incredible activities,
so I was more --
I was more, like, focused on
riding behind a reindeer,
and they have, like --
You can jump into the water.
-I wanted to ask you about this,
because they do --
They have a thing where you can
jump into a frozen lake.
-Yeah.
And you posted
a little video of it,
but tell me about
the experience.
Was it amazing?
-Well, it was awful.
That's a -- I don't know --
The people that do the polar
plunges -- this is not who I am.
This is what
I've learned about myself.
-You're not
a polar plunger at all, no.
-No, I don't think so.
But I said yes.
I was, again, trying to sort of,
like, impress my boyfriend.
Apparently, I'm very insecure
about my boyfriend.
-No, this is --
He takes great photos, and...
But wait. So, what happens?
And what time
of the day is this?
-So, we went at night.
We had this
beautiful spa that's, like,
right on the corner of the
little edge of the lake there.
And the guide
sort of brings you over there,
and they leave you
in this hot sauna.
And then they're like,
"The hole is over there."
And --
-"The hole is over there"?
That's not what they say.
-I'm not exagger-- Well --
-That's not what they say.
-There's a language barrier.
-Okay, yeah, sure, yeah.
So, you're in the hot tub.
You're getting all --
-It's essentially, like,
a cut-out of the lake,
and there's a ladder
and, like, a flashlight.
And nobody's there.
There's no lifeguard.
There's no attendants
or anything.
So you're like,
"This is a terrible idea."
But we did it,
and it was terrible.
-But you go in, don't you feel,
like, free or something
or don't you feel like
you're a new person?
-No.
-Doesn't it feel like --
-No. I felt cold and I wanted to
go inside and drink a beer.
-We have the video of you
doing the plunge in Finland.
Let's take a look
at you in action.
Sara Bareilles.
-Great.
Oh, my God!
-Dude, you went for it.
-Aah! Oh, my God.
Oh, that's awful!
[ Laughter ]
-You don't know where
you're going to go with that.
You're like, "Oh, my God...
that's awful."
-No, it's just a sinus headache.
It's an immediate, like,
headache, and I ran inside.
And then people were like,
"Let's go again!"
And I was like,
"Not on your life!
No."
-It is Pride Month,
and you wrote and recorded
your hit song "Brave"
almost 10 years ago.
It's become sort of
an anthem for -- Yeah.
What does it feel like
when you --
When people play that
or come up to you and go,
"Thank you for writing
that song" or...
-Oh, my gosh, it is --
it's, like,
the dream, as a songwriter,
to have a song kind of take on
a life of its own.
And I wrote it as a love letter
to a dear friend of mine
who was struggling with
coming out,
and then, over the years,
the song has kind of taken on
a few different lives of its own
and been embraced by
all kinds of communities and
especially the LGBTQ+ community.
And I have so many stories
and letters from people
who said that it was a part of
their coming-out story.
And I just think
it's just so beautiful.
It's so meaningful to me.
-Congrats on that.
I mean, you're so talented.
And I love that
you get to do that
and then you get to do
"Girls5eva."
-Me too.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is, like --
Two seasons are streaming
right now on Peacock,
I should mention.
-None of your friends
are on the show.
-I don't know anyone
involved with this thing.
But when Tina Fey
calls you and says like,
"Sara, we should
do this thing" --
Did you guys
know each other before or...
-She had -- I mean,
I knew her a little bit.
Mm, I mean, I had, like,
stood next to her in line
at a bathroom at a charity.
-That's a great story.
-I think she'll remember.
And I didn't have, like,
the cojones
to say anything at that point.
-But I was like, "Oh, my God,
I'm next to Tina Fey."
And then she had came to see
me in "Waitress,"
and so she had seen me perform.
And, yeah, then I got the call
that they were interested
and had my first Zoom
with Tina and Meredith and --
-Oh, Meredith is amazing.
-Oh, my God, Meredith Scardino,
our creator, showrunner.
-Yep.
-And I was not graceful or cool
or sophisticated at all
in my meeting.
-No? What were you like?
-I, like, screamed,
"I'm so nervous!"
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
On the Zoom.
And they're like, "Oh."
And I'm like,
"Are you sure that you want me?
I don't --
I've never done this before.
I'm not sure I can do it."
Which I've learned
is not the best thing to say
in your first...
-How did you
psyche yourself out of that?
How'd you say
that you can do it?
-Well, I actually had
a sweet conversation --
Again, this is a conversation
about my boyfriend.
-Sounds like a great guy.
We all approve.
We love that guy.
Well-traveled.
Got an eye for the stars,
you know?
-Yeah. Yeah, he's a good guy.
-Yeah.
-He kind of reminded me --
I was struggling with
insecurities about
being able to sort of meet
the challenge of it, and I felt
really out of my depth.
And he's like, "If Tina Fey
believes that you can do this,
why don't you just trust her?
Like, if you can't
find it in yourself,
just trust that
one of your heroes
is not going to put you
in position to fail."
And that was really good advice.
So...yeah.
-Hey, I love that.
See, that's --
-Joe, come on out.
-No, he's not here.
No, Joe's not here.
"Come on out."
I would love if I surprised you
with Joe somewhere coming out.
-I'm like,
"I'll see you at home, later."
-Yeah, "Why are you
coming out here?"
Let's talk "Into the Woods,"
can we please?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is
Stephen Sondheim -- legend.
I mean, one in a zillion.
This is -- When was the last
time this has been on Broadway?
-So, I think the story
sort of goes --
So, this is the first production
that is going into production
since Stephen Sondheim's
passing,
so it's been
a really tender time
for the creative team.
And Steve and James Lapine,
who wrote the book,
are always very involved with
their productions.
And, so, it was written
during the '80s,
sort of surrounding
the AIDS crisis,
and then it was
remounted again after 9/11.
And now this
seems to be the next --
There was another production,
but this is, I think,
the next production on Broadway.
-And do you feel pressure
when you do such a --
like, a work
of Stephen Sondheim
or do you go like,
"Well, you know what?
I love you and you're not here,
and this is a way
to say I love you"?
-I do just try to surrender
and honor the material
as best as I can.
We did a two-week run of this
at Encores! at City Center,
and the process is so quick,
you almost don't have time to
think about anything.
So, we're again kind of doing
this really quickly.
We open at the end of
the month, you know?
So it's fast.
But I think you have to trust --
This show is so special and
so beloved for so many reasons.
It's really dense and complex
and deals with
really deep subject matter
with a lot of humor
and a lot of heart.
And the songs are amazing.
This cast is bonkers.
-Yeah.
Will Joe make an appearance?
-I'm sorry, who?
-Joe.
-You know Joe. Yeah.
But Joe -- Joe may or may not be
there opening night.
-He's going to be so pleased how
much he got mentioned in this.
-He really did
get mentioned a lot.
I can't wait to meet him.
Sara Bareilles, everybody.
"Into the Woods"
returns to Broadway June 28th.